[Music]
my son sacrificed his life to save me
these powers
are not a gift
but a curse
born
out of rage
[Music]
this loose cannon needs to be locked
down
before innocent people start getting
hurt
he's been asleep for 5 000 years
if you find us a cell that can hold him
we'll take care of the rest who's on the
team
i didn't bring a passport we don't need
passports
we're the justice society
black adam we're here to negotiate your
peaceful surrender
i'm not peaceful
nor do i surrender
here we go
i kneel before no one
[Music]
you didn't come here to seek justice
you came to exact revenge
[Music]
you believe you are not worthy
but fate does not make mistakes
[Music]
you have two paths
you can be the destroyer of this world
or you can be its savior
[Music]
black adam
what have your powers ever given to you
nothing but heartache
i was a slave until i died
then i was reborn a god
my son sacrificed his life to save me
[Music]
well i do
my vision has shown me the future
you have two choices
you can be the destroyer of this world
or you can be its savior
that's up to you
behind you
did he just catch a rocket
my powers
are not a gift
but a curse
is born out of rage
[Music]
black on
you believe you are not worthy
but you have two paths
you can be the destroyer of this world
or you can be its savior
the world needed a hero
[Applause]
instead it got me
[Music]
you